snitch on the toast fit up bum snitch on
the toast a snitch on the toast but I'm
bum for the last time you guys
good morning Millennials it's not a good
morning though it is very sad and bad
morning there is a great cloud hanging
over our studio this morning and that
great clouds name is snitch because it
is her last time on the toast forever
and like we'd love to speak in like
grande your statements like me I did a
whole Instagram post about how it was
Margot's last show when I was in
whatever but now Marga's come with me to
Pittsburgh tomorrow cuz I needed her I'm
so tomorrow is Marcus last show but this
is actually we're not being dramatic
like this is Margo's final toto so as
this niche cam like if you ever come
back on the toast you'll be filling in
for Claudia or you'll merely be a guest
she'll just like we'll be doing an audio
episode or something but like this is
the last time things are gonna be the
way that I boy you're gonna fire you
financially sure this is so sad you know
I'm not even sad honestly I'm in the
state where I'm just like completely
resentful of you for leaving us and you
know what you want by the way a million
girls would kill for this job and look
at you running away well [ __ ] obviously
still in the anger stage [ __ ] reef
[ __ ] I have fully accepted and now I'm
just sad I'm the sadler [ __ ] Wow she's
in the anger stage about she I'm sorry I
think she's awesome it's like you know I
have to take on Jackie like all by
myself when it comes to Taylor's mother
things that we stand and I was just I'm
not I'm ill-equipped you know I'm very
non-confrontational and yes I'm sorry
I'm resentful and I'm upset you guys
will have no problem for me today
regarding Taylor Swift so don't worry
about that but you know what I feel the
same way too she backs me up today I
said something you didn't even hear me
what you repeated it so that you would
hear what did she say
you got that at four oh that I get in
that four on Sunday I actually did hear
you both times but I just did she so she
wasn't the answer I wanted to hear so I
just couldn't respond so she ignored me
that hurts well I know it's such a sad
day but we're coming off of such a high
and I just I don't want to be one of
those people who looks at the glass half
full
no but at half empty but one could say
that Margo is ruining our high so she is
she's ruining our high you just got back
from Nashville oh man all it means is
that you've been so incredible you've
been so valuable to this show and we're
just gonna miss you and that's all our
sadness means I'm gonna miss you guys
too you don't see why it is with the
biggest smile understand I just like
feel weird why cuz you're leaving your
family yeah yeah trying the family you
are actually in denial we're all in
different stages I'm in bargaining what
can we do let me give you I don't know
how to break it to you but you live a
very cushy life here at the morning
toast you know you talk back to your
bosses and you get you know most of the
day off it's not gonna happen for you
anymore snacks I'm actually really well
I listened to the snatchler um the
podcast that's just taking the world by
storm really is and it's named after us
on the red carpet being this natural we
were so snatched on the red carpet oh my
god and according to the snatcher like
she's actually looking forward to that
routine or structure I actually I think
the one thing I miss about not miss but
like I kind of envy of people who have
like more like rigorous structures and
their life is like that balance you have
of like always knowing what's coming
next you know for me I just think of
life in terms of like my next meal and
like I just can't stop thinking about
food ever so if you like when you'll
have a schedule like you know what
you're gonna eat in a day and for me so
unpredictable what I'm gonna eat so I'm
jealous of schedule for that yeah I know
what I'm gonna eat today and it's gonna
be absolutely nothing because there were
so many mean comments about how fat I
looked on the red carpet like I could
not believe it like I knew I looked fat
but it's like usually it's like the
trousers are so supportive and
exhausting because people seem to forget
it's also 2019 and that she just does
not fly no totally but like I usually
like know when I look fat no one else
skinny but I'm always like oh I look fat
and then everyone's like no you look
great but this time I was like no I look
fat and everyone's like yeah you look
fat so I will be eating today and I will
see you guys on Monday
when snatchler party when I was not so
hard - I think one bad comment oh my god
I see so there was one comment that was
so me on YouTube so specific that's what
cut her to the core it did ruin my whole
night it can do that and it was just
like how does it feel to have like lost
so much weight like no you they were I
was so about Claudia you look so [ __ ]
fat I can't believe you lost so much
weight like imagine how much of a
[ __ ] whale you were before my [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'm sorry I said that word today
and I have a new
sorry I've been wanting to say this I
have a new rule I'm installing for the
whole internet okay if you are gonna
call someone fat and that is your right
I'm loving this rule it is your right it
is you know 20 19 free speech whatever
you want to call someone fat you want to
be that big of a [ __ ] loser fine go
for it
but I it is now mandatory I'm making an
official decree it is now mandatory that
if you're gonna send me a message
calling me fat
you must also attach that message a
naked photo of yourself I need to see
what everyone who's calling me that
looks like because you must be perfect
Emily Ratajkowski
you must be [ __ ] perfect I want to
see a full photo under fluorescent
lighting completely nude full body wear
bra under work so you're not like
interested in their privates fine all
right but like it's like a medicinal you
know at the doctor's office Medical
person's name just curious I mean
[ __ ] with one two three it was on it
was on YouTube and her name I want to
say was Kathy with a K mmm
and I did block her so I don't know if
we could find it
it just really cut me deep and I've been
feeling like so bad about myself so um I
am now officially like nothing well I
look forward to seeing Kathy with a Ches
body I'm sure it's like an incredible
work of art oh yes I will be sending her
a lawyer letters to mantain a photo of
her yeah I think that's so fair it's
just it's so unfair when someone does it
from an anonymous account it's like if
you're gonna be so open with me like I
need to see what you look like
cuz if you're calling me ugly and fat
when I'm literally so stunning and
snatch like you have got to be like so
[ __ ] perfect looking I just want to
see I've got to see what you look like
it's a feast for that it is a feast for
the eyes okay well I think you looked
incredible we had the best night ever at
the CMAs by the way we really did and I
I get so nervous for those things and it
like it turns into anxiety and just like
all this pressure but it was just so fun
we were having so much fun by the way
and I usually also have that anxiety and
pressure and it was kind of heightened
because earlier in the day we got our
credentials meant to drop off some stuff
and like we were literally the absolute
dead last spot on the carpet like no
respect to this year like yeah we
weren't in Ted last year right behind
green dress oh yes we there was probably
like 50 spots I would say we were 45th
yeah like really bad that most people
don't even if you're like a huge star
you don't go past like the fourth or
fifth spot if you're kind of more
up-and-coming like you'll do most of the
carpet even then you don't usually
always make it down to like the very
local news in Kansas like it's just it's
not likely and we had the worst spot and
I was like really like so afraid that we
weren't gonna get any gas in towards the
beginning of the show we had a lot of
like developing Talent and I was like
damn this is true a lot of behind the
scenes people yeah and it was like damn
this stream is great but like we are not
getting top tier guests at all um and
then literally like I don't know how
this electricity was just by being on
the carpet we're like everyone knew
where we were and all these publicists
were coming up to us like wanting to mom
we're like yeah sure okay recognized
Kelsea Ballerini like literally just
showed up on our stream like she didn't
even have a publicist with her she just
ran up to us it was just so exciting we
want to recap everything and I also want
to talk to the snitch because I just
need to like use her brain while we
still have it hmm country music's
number-one fan how did you feel about
our red carpet coverage I mean like I
Juvonen oats know there was a few times
Oh screaming at the screen but like
that's my own fault because Kelly just
yeah also Riley green like there's just
times I was the whole what about stuff
self-titled album oh there are things
where I was just like and also just
interesting factoids that I made that
would have been helpful but bright much
is why we wanted you to come with it
really turned down her dad is my own
fault I mean I was crying in my bed from
the cold do you imagine what would
happen if I was on the carpet where did
you see me hook him for like an extra
yeah it was literally out of control I
just knew that I like I'm not gonna get
to talk to him for another year no and I
was just like so happy and excited and I
feel like he really got everything we
were saying though I I joined him and we
always thought that like our Sandom was
got kind of being like spoken into the
void but like when you guys said you
were like I don't know if you know but
we're huge fans he's like no I now know
I was like if you know but like we
literally follow you around on tour and
mother I told him we're gonna the
stadium tour and by the way I love that
idea for every birthday he's doing a his
first stadium show I know mark checking
can't come she's like really upset cuz
it's Acts birthday but May 2nd in North
Carolina we need to rent like a huge
house like let's see official do comes
after party no like for sure let's talk
about it later
Jack he's literally scaring the [ __ ] out
of me I know she's really upset it's
decks birthday why can't you go without
something Jack was wanted to ands
getting married
right but also I think that we're seeing
him next week who we are seeing Luke
Holmes next week he's performing in New
York it's a small intimate as well what
table lease Wednesday November 22nd I
heart 22nd not 22nd I'm sorry Wednesday
everyone we can't figure out our
schedule but you guys I need to know
what day of the week but a member number
20 is 20th okay because I was invited to
the Kacey Musgraves screening for her
new special Christmas is she gonna be
there it's on the 19th is she gonna be
there you're just watching it on a
screen like you couldn't watch it that's
a good call is she gonna be there I'm
gonna lose come sing yeah actually I
think apples rotten apples cuz you just
go Kacey Musgraves rotten no she's not
gonna be there honestly Casey my screws
was the only person who didn't get on
the carpet this year
she didn't even she need to interview
she walked with Gigi Hadid which I can't
believe Gigi Hadid was Sarah like well
Hannah brown was you think had a brown
felt so [ __ ] in at okay inadequate
like you I actually felt bad for her
well situation is so crazy and like
Hannah Brown was there or closing and
cat like and they just came from the PCs
and like this crew is everywhere I can't
believe GG's even mixed up with these
people no I know it I didn't say it's so
lowbrow for her but like it kind of
makes certain we were just talking
before the show how like I was Gigi
Hadid absolute number one fan like I
discovered her I really feel that
strongly about that on Real Housewives
of Beverly Hills when no seriously I
discovered her and Yolanda wouldn't let
her eat the almond when she was about to
paint on set of the guest photoshoot
like I really like stand her so hard I
was one of the first people to follow
her on Instagram they members she hung
out with Kendall and Kylie and like her
life changed forever like they were in
New York and I kind of got over her
recently cuz she just became like so
unrelatable I'm like so like out of my
league like I used to feel like I could
be her friend and now like there's no
way
but recently I've really felt like I
starting to stand again like she's
starting to go to events that like she's
now the biggest star in the world she
can do whatever she wants and she's
doing things for fun like yes did
someone from The Bachelor like she's
going to the CMA red carpets just cuz
she wants you she's supporting her
friend Taylor Swift at the Billboard
Music Awards like I just I feel like
it's that Jim Carrey movie where he has
to say yes to everything that's where
she is like Tyler she asked her out and
she had to say yes and then she's just
saying yes to life
I just didn't she's like really like now
at a place in her life where she doesn't
have to work so much she's enjoying all
the food she's worked at like literally
every day for the last five years now
she's just enjoying a lot of the fruits
of her labor and she's just doing things
that like a fun young famous person
should do totally
so I'm really starting to stand again
same back to the Streamy vibe and your
other highlights from the snitch Jim
Gaffigan remembering you and calling you
a good sister perhaps yeah no that was
awesome like that was just and then I
was just like oh cool like Jim Gaffigan
remembers what Who I am
yeah and he else wouldn't follow me that
kind of serum in time you know I thought
you guys didn't literally an amazing job
like it was so good I was literally
eating it out those it was just it was
it was it felt like my night you know
what I mean yeah and we were staying out
like it kind of made us want to do more
red carpet coverage but I don't know if
I would have been like so [ __ ] jazz
at like a pop music thing like I don't
know because we've never done it but
like I just feel so strongly about
country music and like these people I
stand so hard and support so much like
it made it so much better also I feel
like country music artists respect the
hell out of the toast and I don't know
that I could say the same about pop very
sure I agree with that I think we would
have a blast it pop anywhere I've
listened to probably equal parts pop and
country I love pop music and I feel like
even like in the way that I know
up-and-coming country artists like I
know up-and-coming pop artists too like
their music so I think we would actually
do a much better job than you give
ourselves credit for but I agree that
they wouldn't respect the hell yeah I
don't know that you get home right who
like and everyone who's like everyone on
their team like knows what's good and
the toast is what sounds right also we
need to give a major shout out to
Xfinity I can I believe we're on
television like that is so cool I know
so many toasters have expended and we're
able to watch us just by picking up
their little remote mean like a show me
the morning shows so cool like the
closest we'll ever get to having our own
TV show very much here for it and they
also sponsored a extra performance of
Lady Antebellum which was so good and
the Lady Antebellum Halsey collab was
amazing this amazing we're such a show
the CMAs were amazing also you know I
realize there's like no awards it's kind
of nice like they're more meaningful
like they are always like 10 Awards and
their phone it's a really big deal if
you win one so I was like why is there
so many performances which I wasn't mad
about I was just like where the [ __ ] are
the awards and then I realized when I
was looking up all the list of nominees
there's only like 10 like major awards
oh so I guess I think I had forgotten I
hadn't seen like Kacey Musgraves saying
in a while but when she started singing
with Willie Nelson I was like butter
noise showed him up yeah by the way
welcome percent I need men is this
amateur next I'm sorry no I know he's
respect to Willie Nelson but like she
just it was heaven
yes she was absolutely hers you to
heaven I made Ben watch and he like
couldn't even like he was being so
annoying you know when you like you make
someone watch I mean like I like I'd
tears my eyes like you need
seen this away I'm seeing no it was so
frustrating he was like playing with me
like [ __ ] watch okay I'm trying to
show you magic yeah magic really
frustrating something really wanted them
to like do more rainbow
michio course and the way they ended it
was beautiful um I didn't like to live
for her jumpsuit but like she can
literally do no wrong in my eyes she
could've worn a piece of duty and I
would have been like it's stunning
it would have been stunning yes we can
do two haven't made one since Monday
yeah Wow are you feeling better though
has the belly I'm like now constipated
which is so much better than having
diarrhea and I'm like not even mad about
it you know I know it's like technically
a problem that I'm a chat since Monday
but cut here for it yeah I'm happy for
you also one of my favorite highlights
was the home free guys like they're
always so incredible I just could watch
a clip over and over again like it was
just they're so good and they're so nice
and they respect the hell on the toes
that's the thing right that's the thing
that's the only sit it on their
Instagram yeah yeah well it was a great
night thank you everyone for watching
thank you for all of the positive
feedback except for Kathy with acai you
can go [ __ ] yourself
um and without further ado I do feel as
though it is time for the past five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast because honestly like the
stories need to be discussed
no but it's time and I'm I'm not arguing
with that and you know I'm very you know
argumentative but I'm not arguing
arguing with that but do you feel like
you might be rth I might be remiss to
have a shadow and a heart broken if I
don't let you know that today's episode
is brought to you by attitude because we
got that attitude we've got the attitude
if you want to get the best sleep of
your life you've got to try attitude
sheets we have them and I've had them
for a while but after spending over a
week in other people's beds well hotel
rooms I just made myself sound like it's
like a slot know for a week there is
truly nothing like coming home to your
own bed and didn't even realize like the
difference in quality of sheets after
having spent so many nights alone I got
homeless and I'm like why am i sleeping
so differently because my attitudes cuz
you had that attitude that's the thing
they're feathery soft
literally organic clean bamboo is
extremely breathable material that
regulates your temperature to improve
improve your quality of sleep so I'm a
deep sleeper which means I sweat like I
wake up with like a puddle of sweat it
between my breasts it's like soda Scott
saying and having like comfort
technology like temperature control
cheats has truly been a life changer
like I you should just sleep with one
leg outside the comforter like that
doesn't even do anything I don't
the problem was my sheets because my
sheets weren't made of organic clean
bamboo it's an antimicrobial material
some of the attitude customers have
claimed that their skins appearance
improved after switching to edited
sheets you can read the reviews and see
if yourself very true a lot of people
don't realize like dirty towels and
sheets or the reason why you have like
pimples oh it's so important for your
skin organic clean bamboo recycles 98%
of the water it uses so it's the most
sustainable bedding available cotton
uses a ton of pesticides and waste water
is harmful on the environment if you
want to give a gift that there is that
the recipient will love and future
generations will thank you for give the
gift of attitude sheets so a holiday
season is upon us what is a better gift
than the gift of sleep no there's no
better gift why not why not try attitude
these amazing sheets have a 30-day
risk-free trial if you're not fully
satisfied you can return your sheets for
a full refund
they even cover shipping on returns by
the way that's a game-changer attitude
sheets they're soft as silk breathable
as linen but at the price of cotton you
or that special someone you buy them for
are going to love them and right now our
listeners will get 20% off their first
sheet set and free shipping text toast
to 64000 and that's the only way to get
the 20% off your set of attitude sheets
and free shipping is to text toast TOA
st obviously to 64000 again that's toast
to 64000 you'll get 20% off your set of
edited sheets and free shipping when you
text toast to 64000
signing on get that attitude what's up
from Cheetah Girls the best movie ever
the best movie ever even if you find out
your dad died in the middlee yes just
still watch it it's okay it's laughs yep
okay the first story I'm really like the
big story of the day and I'm like scared
for everyone but don't worry like I'm
not coming for you ladies I'm just here
to report the news because Taylor Swift
has put out a statement saying I don't
know what else to do
well margot face how many shows you see
chosen screaming like no and like my
first thing i was like oh my god there's
a new album you know like i'm so ready
and like this is not the news I wanted
to hear like no no or maybe an epic
sacramentary but not like this yeah but
not like this right it's like a lot of
news and like the worst possible right
like tied in a ribbon of [ __ ] yeah guys
it's been announced recently
mrs. Taylor speaking guys it's been
announced recently that the American
Music Awards will be honoring me with
artist of the decade award at this
year's ceremony I've been planning to
perform a medley of my hits throughout
the decade on the show like obviously
because she's artist of the decade Scott
Borchetta and Scooter Braun have now
said that I'm not allowed to perform my
old songs on television because they
claim that would be rear according my
music before I'm allowed to next year
additionally and this isn't the way I
had planned on telling you this news
Netflix has created a documentary about
my life for the past few years Scott and
scooter have declined the use of my
older music or performance footage for
this project even though there is no
mention of either of them or big machine
records anywhere in the film Scott
Borchetta told my team that they'll
allow me to use my music only if I do
these things if I agree to not re-record
copycat versions of my songs next year
which is something I'm both legally
allowed to do um looking forward to and
also my team that I need to stop talking
about him and Scooter Braun I feel very
strongly that sharing what is happening
to me could change the awareness level
for other artists and potentially help
them avoid a similar similar fate this
message being sent to me is very clear
basically be a good little girl and shut
up or you will be punished this is wrong
neither of these men had a hand in
writing these songs they did nothing to
create the relationship I have with my
fans so this is where I'm asking for
your help please let Scott and scooter
know how you feel about this scooter
also manages several artists who I
believe care about other artists and
their work please ask them for help with
this I'm hoping that maybe they can talk
some sense into the men who are
exercising tyrannical control over
someone who just wants to play the music
she wrote she's so she's asking for help
from her fans um because she's obviously
at a dead end yeah and this is like
really [ __ ] sad so this was a put out
yesterday and since then the world has
just been shaken to its core shake it
you shook is to its core artists have
come out in support of Taylor and then
Big Machine released a statement saying
um like saying that these are this is
false quote as Taylor's partner for over
a decade we were shocked to see her
tumblr statements yesterday based on
false information at no point did we say
Taylor could not perform on the AMAs or
block her Netflix special in fact we do
not have the right to keeping her from
performing live anywhere since Taylor's
decision to leave Big Machine last fall
we have continued to honor all of her
requests to license her catalogue to
third parties as she promotes her
current record in which we do not
financially participate what you're
gonna die what literally what did I say
was gonna happen before we started the
show this is here oh my god no way
yeah MJ Mercedes Javid on the scheduled
literally for a week and she hasn't
answered any of my texts or emails we
just figured she wasn't coming she's
[ __ ] here oh I'm so excited okay
great okay we need to aggregate
questions oh my god I'm Margo just
literally technician MJ is here we were
talking about I'm like oh we followed up
with her yesterday I texted her idea her
like literally that is so [ __ ] funny
she's in town for Bravo con oh my god
I'm dying that is so funny I can't
believe like this inch isn't here in the
middle of the biggest Sykes noaina story
okay so let me continue become easily
they're saying this is false and when I
read this is always what happened this
is always what happens when I read
Taylor's first statement I was like oh
my god if this is true like this is
terrible and now they're saying it's
false so I'm like okay where do we still
lose in anyway tree pain who is Taylor's
publicist who really changed her her
whole career edge subset posted on
Twitter the truth is on October 28th
2019 at 5:17 p.m. the vice-president
rights management and business affairs
from Big Machine label groups sent
Taylor's team to swap the following
message quote please be advised that be
MLG will not agree to issue licenses for
existing records or waivers of its rear
according restrictions in connection
with these two projects the Netflix
documentary and the Alibaba double 11
event which is the event that Taylor
just did in China and China to avoid an
argument over rights Taylor perform
three songs off her new album lover at
the double 11 event as it was clear that
big machine felt any televised
performance of catalogue songs violated
her agreement in addition yesterday
Scott Borchetta flatly denied the
request for both American Music Awards
and Netflix please notice in Big Machine
statement they never actually deny
either claimed Taylor said last night in
her post
lastly big machine is trying to deflect
and make this about money saying she
owes them but an independent
professional auditor has determined that
big machine owes Taylor 7.9 million
dollars of unpaid royalties over several
years that is so crazy like not that I
ever doubted
Taylor but like this is true receipts
like and I'm just I'm very much happy
like with with where we're at right now
um I just like I need the fighting to
stop like it really hurts my soul and
it's like I know that as a Taylor stand
who's always trying to change people's
hearts and minds about Taylor like I
know this makes people not like Taylor
because I like I get there like it makes
her look greedy like she's a almost a
billionaire like what the hell does she
care no not even that it just makes her
look like she's always complaining right
and like always fighting with people and
at the end of the day at the core of
this argument like it's a real
conversation
that should be had and like I just hate
that when when people who don't like
Taylor Swift like are talking about her
it's always about things like this and
it's like can't we just talk about how
great and talented and smart and funny
and like great she is like and and I
hate that we're talking about it because
it just gives people who don't like her
like fodder to say that she's annoying
do you know but then also we stuff like
this and clearly this is a big issue for
artists like who don't own their past
music it shines a light on like these in
justices in the industry and a lot of
times like she makes change happen like
of course for like streaming platforms
when she left Spotify yeah and having
artists I get paid and also what she did
when she left a big machine and went to
Universal Music Group was part of her
deal was like alright I'll sign with
Universal Music Group like yeah I'm the
biggest star in the world I know you
want me but in order for me to come on
you have to change like your payment
structure for all your artists so like
even people like Nicki Minaj sure like
her on like a big and small there
they're like livelihood was impacted
just by Taylor Swift moving record
labels like she's always fighting for
other artists smaller artists and it's
like the fact that people don't see that
like it's so frustrating and like I
literally can't argue with people on the
internet anymore about it like I used to
get so in the weeds like on comments
just like fighting with people and it's
just it's so frustrating like yeah it's
people are so [ __ ] dumb but I guess
the good thing here is like they're
saying that they didn't say these things
so great she should go perform her songs
at the AMAs and do her Netflix
documentary and if they come for her
like with lawyers like she'll post that
to her tumblr - you know what's so great
is like the last time we had this fight
like we didn't know how it ended now
it's like the AMAs is the endgame like
whatever happens at the AMAs is it we'll
see what's really going on you know so
I'm very much the ratings for the Emmys
just went tenfold yes yeah oh and then
we got like it was like the best news
ever delivered in the worst possible way
like we're getting a [ __ ] Netflix
special like not even like a concert
like a [ __ ] documentary
yeah with performances she said they're
trying to access like old footage of old
performances I'm just I'm so here for it
I just don't understand how this doesn't
we don't hear about this or this doesn't
happen to artists more often because I
feel like there's so many artists like
Taylor who are you know huge who have
been around for at least ten years who
have early music that someone else owns
but how is we've never confronted this
issue before like who owns Madonna's
early right I do think that Taylor Swift
is unique in the sense that she shot to
stardom like a level that no one has
ever seen while all being under the same
contract like what usually you like sign
a contract
while you got a new contract like not
only think many people at the age of 13
have a 10 year contract you know what
I'd like and in that 10 years it's like
your biggest hits ever it's like usually
you'll sign maybe I don't know how it
works I think like two years and it's
like maybe you have one good song in the
two years you know yeah it's so gradual
and like you moved from label to label
like you don't get a [ __ ] 10-year
contract and also it happened to have
the biggest success of your career in
those 10 years yeah you know I will say
just one thing because I feel like Scott
Borchetta as an animal for sure yeah
like I I kind of a trust Scooter Braun
for some reason I feel and so that's the
only thing that's not adding up cuz he
seems like a decent guy he has so many
friends in the industry so many people
respect him he does really great work
and he already knows that this is a very
contentious thing like Taylor Swift
Merces him and I I feel like he really
does not want to be a part of this
narrative hmm so that's the part that
doesn't make sense to me
you know I know that like whatever's
going on right now like Scott Borchetta
takes this personally like to me Scott
Borchetta is like a disgruntled
ex-employee like who is such a like a
like a nerd like I know that looked a
lot he's really you know that like
character from you know like Nashville
the show that recording and Zack who's
like evil and just like you know preys
on the talent squeezes the juices out of
it like he's that bill in this character
for sure yeah and I know that the Taylor
Swift is fandom Swifty's like really
don't like Scooter Braun and I haven't
decided how I feel about him yet just
because like I have watched him as like
a just like a purveyor of talent like
he's always on to something you know
what I mean like so I know there's
rumors about him that he's like a snake
in a rat and like Evo but like I haven't
seen that yet so like once I see it I
will agree with it but I'm very much
like I'm putting this entire thing on
Scott Borchetta
it's easy to do that but that's just
like the one piece of the puzzle that
doesn't get up for me um and I feel like
we're gonna like even now she's released
this statement maybe someone else will
speak up maybe I all will say something
she always likes to you know clarify
some things and like let us see the
human side of scooter that's true
because like it's easy for for people to
see him it's just like this big machine
yeah just like sweeping up all you know
the checks yeah um so I just I really
want peace for everyone though you know
this is so annoying but also this is
people that I love are fighting and it
really just comes back down to you like
Kim versus Taylor and then when you
can't pick a side it you will struggle
also it's like we were just in Nationals
like all those country artists big
Sheen record label holders like those
are talented artists and they everyone
here deserves justice like this is a
conversation that needs to be had and
I'm glad that Taylor Swift is
spearheading it but I feel like because
so many people love to hate on telecon
verse a shion's not being taken
seriously enough you know like if this
was something taken very seriously I
really really do like and other artists
are supporting her like Halsey posted I
really did ariana grande say anything
because to me it's like her relationship
with scooter is a big reason why I just
like scooter yes so I would like to know
what she thinks yeah Halsey is spoken up
I'm honestly not nauseous not a lot of
people tonight she's an enormous GE look
everyone you would expect G I mean but
like where's Katy Perry barelli's yeah
because she's friends with scooter and
now she's friends with Taylor and she's
also like a decade-long artist who must
feel some type of way yeah I don't know
if her masters are worth that much in
comparison to Taylor Swift obviously no
but not even worth anything but like can
she perform songs that she wrote on a
different record label and even if she
can like seeing this happening to
another artist and like even though
scooters are friendly how do you feel
about this yeah I just think there are
very few people like in the industry who
can relate to the problem Taylor's
having just because no one is really as
successful as her no one's masters are
worth that much and no one has as
contentious of a relationship with their
former label like I think if you wrote a
song from another label and you want to
perform it it's like sure you'd have to
pay the licensing fee like it's not that
big of a deal unless you're Taylor Swift
do you know what I mean I disagree like
Beyonce where are her songs from 10
years ago rihanna where her songs from
10 years ago like i'm saying i'm sure
they're at other labels but it's not
contentious many people perform songs
that they wrote years before and
probably are benefiting other people but
there's like a there's a structure like
you have to pay this fee or whatever
like there's a way to do it and i think
that most of the time it's not
contentious so it's just contentious cuz
it's like scrapped because of a fee and
there's this whole drum yeah okay we're
just talking about like that it this is
true it's seriously [ __ ] up and there
needs to be a better way and also the
only piece of the puzzle doesn't add up
for me it's like I think that scooter is
a good guy so like where why is this
happening that's how I deal maybe he's
not you know it's just like I want to
live under this cloud that Scooter Braun
is a great guy because like I love his
interest
and his wife but this if this is
happening he's obstinate about it let's
not let's not be naive yeah yeah I know
and that's just like that's the part
that's hard for me to swallow you know
yeah and I'm not just gonna implicitly
believe that and I also want to hear
like from him and maybe I'll know I
really do think that Scott is like the
worst of the worst
he is just wait that's our vote he's put
it all on him but like Scott is the nerd
who like got popular and became evil do
you not even like lost his moral compass
you know but it's it's easy to put it on
him but like the two of them are in
business together like right scooter
could sailing and also like honestly if
it's if this is true yeah but it's like
there are receipts here so it varies
that there's pure evidence whether or
not this is true or not for them to me
no literally also but tree pain she put
it out there yeah so how long they'll go
back and forth I know like eventually
someone just stops answering yeah
eventually someone gives in and lets but
honest and it's literally next weekend
even with these receipts like I'm really
big on like precedent so I just want to
know compared to other artists like what
what about this deal is just like worse
than what it is for other people you
know what I mean like what's I know like
it's a but it is a business you know so
even though it's someone's art and like
someone's you know diary entries from
ten years ago
like their contracts are signed what did
it say what would she be violating and
isn't it's different from what everyone
else has signed right and it's like how
do you say that Taylor owes you money
and then Taylor says that you owe her
money like thanks Bonnie it's one or the
other I think we need an episode of
American greed about this no we just
need like a fully like a third party
like investing like we need a pie oh I'm
so confused about it's like if this is
true and they are like basically
blackmailing her like they already know
that she's not afraid to speak up so
like why wouldn't they think that she
was gonna do it again
I just want to say I love her doing this
I think there's so much power and just
going directly to the people and just
like telling them what's going on it's
because sometimes that's all you have is
your voice and like she clearly like
feel like she's backed into a corner and
she had nothing else to do and this is
like the biggest move that she could
have done that I love when artists do
this and our transparent with their fans
about what's going on because like I
think that will affect change so like
just her going and not even going to a
media outlet like just her writing in
her note app on her phone
yeah I'm singing to her tumblr like dark
mode I very much yes she's protecting
you I heard that must have been for her
to announce a Netflix documentary right
now right
she loves to like drag this Internet and
she was like and now that's been taken
away right thanks a cop or Shepherd I I
so respect her decision to do this and I
think it's a baller [ __ ] them me too
I just say a hot take here that not
enough people are talking about is I
don't care whose side you're on but
everyone is like responding to this like
in a way that's really pissing me off
and they're like Alexa play the man and
it's like okay we get it like the man is
like a female empowerment song like this
is a moment where a female is not being
empowered but like it's so lame and like
everyone thinking they're original for
coming up with it like I have to give
credit like the first place I saw it was
e-news and like in there I thought it
was like cute and funny but like a
little lame now I ever made like Alexa
play okay Google
shut the [ __ ] up like I just like you're
ruining that song for me and I think
it's the best songs to [ __ ] off
and now buy the right now more than ever
I'm really standing firm in the fact
that I think the man is gonna be her
next thing I like if she has to end
whatever happens at the Amy's hopefully
she can perform her own music because
now big machine is saying that she never
couldn't write so let's say I hope she
ends with a man like that would be a
wonderful judge she's no doubt gonna
play the man well wondering in fact but
wait I also have something else to say
because I know that everyone's making
this like a moment for females but it's
like this happens to men too and this
isn't just maybe your scholarship
creators and just intellectual justice
and it's definitely worse because it's
happening like by powerful men to a
woman and like I totally get that but
it's not just this is not a problem that
just affects women it affects artists
yes I don't want that to get lost like
this happens to Justin Timberlake you
know what I mean yeah but does it is my
question
I don't yeah I just want to see some
contracts you know and then I don't know
how to read them so I'll send them to
someone to read yeah we've learned
history for sure
okay there's a group are you ready for
our next story because it's a bit more
of positive news okay rounding an award
show Alicia Keys is hosting the 2020
games again I heard whoohoo she did a
great job last year if it ain't broke
don't fix it everyone respects her she's
not controversial like no one has beef
with her she's perfect I love her energy
she's so talented she can sing she could
talk she can just like inspire I think
this is a great choice she gives me like
the same vibe of Kelly Clarkson at the
BBM a is like super talented very
well-respected in her field not
controversial doesn't have beef with
anyone like universally well-liked
speaking of Kelly Clarkson
I watched the Morning Show last night I
watched all the episodes that are
available now yes and I inadvertently
subscribe to Apple plus I think and I
really enjoyed it
I'm gonna watch not the greatest show of
all time and I feel like I've read some
reviews where people were iffy about it
um and I feel like it might like it's
what snubbed at awards season uh but I
think it's a really interesting take on
literally exactly what's going on right
now in a broadcast and with you know
like Matt Lauer but it's also not so
black and white it's it's interesting
and it makes you think in it's a lot
about like cancel culture and just like
the court of public opinion and but it's
not so cut and dry because like Steve
Carell is not a great guy but like I
don't think he's meant to be Matt Lauer
right but he has a button under his test
that locks the door he does yeah but
everyone at the show loves him hmm
so it's inch it makes you think and I
think that's important and they're there
and they're saying things and having
conversations it's easier when it's
through fictional characters you know
because it's like I'm not the one here
saying this right um but it's
interesting that Reese Witherspoon is so
[ __ ] cute and I'm loving your
character and judge her at the CMAs I
have to say yes sitting next to Nicole
Kidman it's the best seat in the house
Jennifer Aniston's characters really
complex because she's like an aging
woman in news and on the one hand like
she's competitive with everyone and will
do whatever it takes it on the other
hand she's lifting up Reese but then
she's also inevitably like a little
jealous when she has more success in
hurts it's very interest I understand
it's very interesting and I would
recommend it okay and you know I love a
show about a morning show I've so much
traveling to do this weekend hitting up
Pittsburgh and Philly both shows are
sold out sorry you can't come but I did
that a bunch of shows you can go for
girl with no job calm and hitting up
Canada again we're going to or really
Ontario at the rama casino it cuz you
know and I'm also gonna be turning them
stones right jex
turn them stones y'all you guys it's
almost time and I just want you know
when's Turning Stone I don't know
whenever it is I just want like can you
get a video of the crowd like just
turning stones like you everyone
everyone is where you're BYO anybody OS
bring your own stone and then we're
gonna turn on me off Verona Dec attend
so poorly
I think that's illegal that's called
stony oh my god that's so funny
don't bring your own stones I'm sorry
take that back Tarrytown New York sorry
times pretty much sold out I might have
a second child cuz I can keep saying yes
oh you keep saying it
Tarrytown Verona New York Ontario Kansas
City Oh at Lenox Kansas City Oh Kansas
City Missouri Englewood New Jersey and
Atlantic City New Jersey all December
January the tour's over in January and I
know I keep saying that it's over but
like it is actually over like I will be
stopping um and I just think that you
should come see me if you haven't seen
me um
tickets available at girls no job com
can't stress that enough you know were
they available girl was no job com yeah
also stop touching your mic oh I just
love to hold it I know it's a thing that
you have good was it ever since we have
the new mics but it does make a sound
does it I don't think it does we heard
it I'll keep holding it okay are you
ready for our next story some more
injustice in the industry I am I am
industry brought to you by it's love it
whatever reaction you're looking for
this holiday you can spread more joy
with custom holiday cards calendars and
photo gifts from mr. print Theo is
actually sending out his own holiday
cards ask him if he wants to do like a
group family thing he said no mom I got
this something I'm going to miss soprano
he's so independent guess what it
doesn't actually take much time at all
here's all you have to do to create a
holiday gift card a holiday card pick a
shape like square around it corners
folded her flat and then choose one of
his two prints designs they've got
everything from fun and festive gorgeous
and eye-catching luxe next you put your
favorite picture right there the most
options you can even upload a great shot
right from your phone then you just
figure out how many you need and order
them with no time to spare this one of
the hardest parts like figuring out like
who is worthy of a Theo give a holiday
card honestly I don't think I don't
think anyone in this room is worthy of a
Theo holiday card I think his for his
aunts Nietzsche says he's a good boy
they have hundreds of card designs from
timeless classics to funded trends they
also have custom calendars for gifts
that keep on giving all year round I'm
going to make been like a sexy boudoir
or calendar I think you'll really enjoy
that
you different for getting her that
opportunity you can also upload your
favorite photos right from your phone
and save on mugs canvases and other
photos gifts your satisfaction is 100%
guaranteed or they'll make it right
either by reprinting your order or
offering a refund holiday is the best
time of year hard to get gifts for a lot
of people but I think this print it's
time good
options this season make more Marriott
vistaprint.com with up to 50% off all
holiday cards and photo photo calendars
plus great deals on photo gifts at
vistaprint.com
just enter the promo code toast 50
that's vistaprint.com the promo code is
toast 5-0 the offer expires January 5th
so it's more than enough time to get 50%
off all holiday cards and photo
calendars toast 50 is the promo code at
vistaprint.com I love that I actually
have them something up my sleeve for
family for that regards to the surprise
so stay tuned for that also you know
what be a great gift for someone to make
them business cards you know yeah Thanks
so toast 50 that's actually a good idea
yeah I'm gonna make you some card is
that you like suddenly telling me wait
you know I definitely want to make
actually last time I made my own cards
you guys know how that went and double
looking like a broth or brothel yeah and
no one even came to the brothel so so so
like no one even called me or anything
um I got confirmation that I don't make
a sound when I touch my mouth that's
when I bang into it um but let's get
into the injustice in the industry shall
we sure you don't seem excited but I
wouldn't planted there I don't know
Victoria's Monique files racism
discrimination suit against Netflix I am
so invested in this because I can't
believe how like how I felt and then now
how I feel you know what I mean okay
well here's here's the deets
Monique filed a discrimination suit
against Netflix on Thursday alleging
that the streaming service broke the law
when it gave her a lowball offer for a
comedy special the comedian whose legal
name is Monique Hicks accused Netflix of
race and sex discrimination in January
2018 Monique called for a boycott of
Netflix saying she had been offered just
five hundred thousand dollars for a
special while Amy Schumer was offered 11
million and Dave Chappelle and Chris
Rock were offered 20 million the suit
accuses Netflix of a lack of diversity
in its senior leadership ranks and a
history of insensitivity to black people
which by the way I didn't know and when
I read MSNBC did a huge article on it
and like it was shocking there was like
an executive who kept using the n-word
like it was and he wouldn't apologize
for it like it was crazy oh my god that
is crazy the suit also cites figure
stating that black people make up only
6% of the Netflix workforce as of 2019
okay so when I first heard this I was
like honestly this is just like why are
you complaining like no offense like
you're not that famous like that's I
thought like on
so I was just thinking I'm like I don't
think the offer is low because of who
you are I think it's because you're not
relevant anymore but then when I saw the
number it's like it was shocking and I
didn't really know that Netflix had this
like really terrible history like I
couldn't believe like it's not an
isolated it's not an isolated night
actually
I loved Monique and she's worthy of so
much more like to me like I don't well
hey yeah like it's it's hard to compare
yourself to like Dave Chappelle right
here but then this article doesn't
mention an MSNBC did Wanda Sykes is a
good comparison where she walked away
from a Netflix offer like years ago
because it was so low and so and she
spoke out about it a lot and recently
she got a Netflix special and someone
asked her why they're like she she said
they literally moved to the comma like
that's how much they came so she this
isn't the first time they've had a
problem with the black female comedian
and I didn't know that and now I'm
feeling like Monique baby's not is she's
not being dramatic
no I don't think she's being dramatic
and she is constantly speaking up for
injustice so true and I think she's
really like going out on the limb here
because it's the right thing to do and
then nobody wants to go against Netflix
it's like the biggest powerhouse like
you're gonna make yourself enemy number
one like this is a brave thing to do and
I don't think that she would have done
it if like she was just like wanting
like if it was just really about the
money yeah I totally agree and like even
if she's not necessarily as same as says
Amy Schumer like there was a big there's
a lot of numbers you could choose in
between five hundred thousand and eleven
million right and it's also really
interesting because then it's like it
also then shows so Amy Schumer got 11
million whereas like Dave Chappelle
Chris Rock and Jerry Seinfeld are 40 60
and 100 now I know Amy Schumer is no
Jerry Seinfeld but she's not that far
away from like a Chris Rock she still is
like one of the biggest as a theme i
they would say she's the biggest female
comedian in the world yes so it's like
the biggest female comedian gets 11
million and Jerry Seinfeld gets a
hundred right the biggest female
comedian gets less than like the third
biggest male comedian right so like even
in in their argument it's like yes Amy
Schumer got way less because she's women
and Monique got way way way way way less
because she's a black woman yeah so you
know what I was like really being
convinced by this article I'm I'm
convinced I'm I am with Monique yeah
however no meet you and also like I want
a Monique special so like from can we
make this work also then I would love to
really see the success of the specials
because I feel like Netflix doesn't
really have a good like temperature on
what people want and I feel like I'm
always seeing specials by people like
nobody asks
you know I want to know I want to know
the return on investment like how much I
want to list of like the last 20
specials like how much people got paid
and then how many people actually
watched it that this is what I want to
know that what might put things into
perspective for me just like I need you
know the contracts for Taylor Swift I
want to know how much Miranda sings got
paid and if it was more or less than
Monique yeah and then I'll make up my
mind you know what because she deserves
I mean mone deserves more that's
actually a great point okay so yeah that
was like no events like the special
nobody asked for you know yeah I mean
and we're also like not her target time
I went aside like she I'm all about
internet people may had Apple ting
getting Netflix specialist email me
Hello at morning - Oh show all about it
but I just I just need a little context
I like to see precedent and the other
perspective it's actually a really good
call I think and you know what if
Netflix is really like not so [ __ ] up
they should release all of that to show
that they don't that they don't
discriminate also speaking of that's
what I show if i were innocent
Jaggi speaking netflix specials that we
haven't really spoken about is john
Crist his Netflix special is being
temporarily out on hold after there was
like a many an allegation he put his
hold he canceled the whole rest of his
tour John Christie is by the way and I
literally like don't know or like would
have never known who he was because
we're so not his target ever gonna ban
he's a Christian comedian which is I
think what makes this whole situation
like more of like a click Beatty moment
um but he very briefly dated Lauren
Alaina and actually Mia Marco met him
when we were in Milwaukee because we
both had shows that night and I thought
it was like a nice guy yeah I didn't get
any you know Matt Lowry vibes but
allegedly he's in our um and Netflix put
a whole lot of special like okay thanks
for doing the right thing you know yeah
interesting I read one article about it
and it's just like there was only one
article about it and it was on like a
very small Christian news saying that's
what I kept see but it made enough waves
for him to cancel the rest of his world
tour and for Netflix put a hold on a
special that was supposed to come out
Thanksgiving next week oh [ __ ] yeah
Christian blogs making news making news
okay are you ready for our next story a
little young romance because Pete
Davidson and Kaia Gerber are making it
official stepping out together spotted
etc it's it's
he literally like was dating Andie
McDowell's daughter like not two minutes
you know it's crazy and by the way we
totally broke this news I just because
they were at sea Dells together and
while I really I mean I just I guess I
just love Pete Davidson and I ship him
with anyone but he also like keeps going
with the same girl so it's like easy to
ship no kya Gerber and the girl before
are twins and with the Cassie David
there's really no by the way all of this
you know spiraling this dating a piece a
button is just making me realize he's
longing for Cassie David right now he's
dating sassy favorites right where's
like Cassie David had the aesthetic that
he wanted but I think they also really
connected on a deep level I'm like if
you would have told me while they were
dating that I wouldn't have worked out I
would have been shocked because like
they were perfect for each other
um and she has too much pride and she's
too cool to like ever go back with him
after what he did to her but like they
really I think are OTP and he'll spend
the rest of his life trying to find the
next Cassie yeah but um must feel so
good for Cassie though you know right
it's like she really was like humiliated
like the whole thing happened like
totally she had no idea she was
blindsided and now it's like she's
really like in the driver's seat
you know she's got an amazon show he's
dating fazzy faman let's field yeah yeah
I'm sure I'm sure that it does uh also
he was eating Kate back and say like
he's been just really busy
yeah actually couldn't like them
together I know and I also and I liked
him in um margaret quali together
because i saw her once upon a time in
hollywood and i like him in kya gerber
together and i just like i want him to
find love um and make it last and I also
you know I actually like love him and
Ariana Grande together I know that I
just lazy time I missed that time I
missed those whole foods glamour
stepping out no apart no furniture in
the apartment like I missed the whole
mood I miss it all she had a song on her
album named after him Pete Davidson guys
I think they weren't just like meant to
be I don't I love them I think they were
so destructive like for both both it was
definitely like the most toxic
relationship of all time I miss them so
much so much happened in such a short
period of time like the tattoo a toxic
relationship like become on toxic it's
like the two people they've been apart
for a while like say they both like
became on toxic on their own maybe like
then the love is there like a baby like
mature and sad I've never been in a
toxic relationship except my
relationship with you is very toxic oh
it's so toxins are always like really
like coming for me and like in like
giving me so much self-doubt you know
really emotional support a kid oh he's
so supportive I think you're just like
putting too much on him sometimes
well actually it's only like 18 pounds
filled was a real service animal this
weekend while he was when me and Ben
were in Morocco I've gotta tell you guys
this we were staying a Theo was staying
at Ben's parents and Ben's sister how to
create she's very allergic to a lot of
thing things should have crazy allergic
ration went to the hot to the emergency
room what Theo drove up to Philly and
was it emotional support animals they
feel found her no Theo was just so I
feel like a sense that something was
wrong he was just supportive no but you
know I don't know if she would have
recovered as quickly as she did I don't
she would have been calling uber he
rented a car actually uh Ben's mom drove
so oh he borrowed Ben's mom's car yeah
actually Ben Theo did sit in the
driver's seat with Ava because he loves
to sit in the front seat you know yeah
and he does love driving for uber like
he has five-star rating yeah by the way
he's like he's gonna get his own chair
member at Cash Cab like he got his own
show he was gonna get his own Bravo Joe
I totally see it and watched Cash Cab
but I kind of like like the idea um I
like it yeah and I like watching I like
the commercials yeah and I just like
seeing Bravo liberties like in different
environments and I just like a new
format being brought to Robert like a
late-night game show that's 30 minutes
okay writin but it's also a reboot yeah
and also anything that's not that show
like a man Oh totally every time I see a
commercial I just like I feel like I'm
being Punk'd you know I know it's so
dumb it's so dumb it's so dumb I can't
also I've caught up on all housewives me
too except for Orange County Oh Orange
County mmm it wasn't a great episode but
it's setting you up for a good one yeah
there's too many conversations like one
on one two on one where it's like let's
get the group together and let's all
talk about it yeah okay the final story
a little college news is because
Georgetown has done a study
measuring whether college is worth it or
not based on the return on investment I
could tell you it's not yeah but what
did they say what does the study say um
it says that some schools are a return
on investment and the top 10 colleges
with the best long-term net economic
gain are Harvard MIT Stanford but then
also no new news no but there are two
public schools that make the top 10 list
and the Marine the main maritime
Academy there's also like a pharmacy and
health side what's the to Public Schools
um it is I don't like they have they
need to break this list down like with
like one two you know they don't think
it's still I'm looking at the study I do
Mike but I thought hold on I'll get it
for my newsletter one second no it's
okay no I actually don't care you don't
know yeah I'm here to tell you like I
would have been more successful like
maybe I would literally own a house
right now if I didn't go to college like
he wasted four years ago I always did
four years of my life so much time money
like trash yeah I know the NYU was on
return-on-investment school shocking
shocking shocking
speaking of shock King by the way you
know we say shocking I'm the commercial
from the commercial for Shahs of Sunset
speaking up we have MJ here we're gonna
run around a minute leave a question for
her please drop it in the YouTube stream
she's here for Bravo Khan is the baby
here no oh she said she was gonna bring
shams ok whatever she dragon also
programming note is that on Monday will
be a podcast only episode because cardi
and I are out of town yes we are before
we bring you out our guests it's time to
let you know who the guest is brought to
you by we're bringing you the guess but
third love is really bringing you the
guest third love the best brought
company it's the only one you really
need to know about I have a personal
anecdote I would like to share I have an
amazing new housekeeper I love her so
much and she was holding my bras and she
was like my daughter has huge tits too
like where'd you get your bras I
literally made her take a picture of
third love because like do you give her
the promo code I did I texted tetes at a
turn she came back last weekend she said
her daughter's loving the bras isn't it
so cute it's so cute over 14 million
women have taken look with the quiz to
date basically you go on third love calm
you fill out a quiz all about your bra
size I think half the battle with
finding the right bra is knowing your
size and I didn't know my real size
until I took the fit finder quiz so many
people have taken it it's super fun it
takes less than a minute to complete
they help you identify your breast size
and shape and it finds a style that fits
your body they have the perfect fit
promise every customer has 60 days to
wear the bra wash it push it push it to
the test but if you don't love it you
can return it and third love will wash
it and donate it to a woman in need
third loves team of expert fit stylists
are dedicated to helping you find the
perfect fit their stylists are available
every day to help via text chat or phone
their returns and exchanges are free and
easy hands down it's a most comfortable
bra you will own I can attest to that I
wear the t-shirt bra pretty much every
day
my boobs do not touch it so crazy I am a
huge size I won't even say it and my
boobs don't a truck I didn't ever think
there was a broad that would literally
separate my boobs like I that's where I
get so much sweat it's like the chafing
when the titties rub up against each
other
sorry to overshare but it's true they
also give back third love donates all
their gently used or return on rich
gently used returned bras to women in
need supporting charities in their local
San Francisco Bay Area and across United
States so far they have donated over 15
million dollars in bras their love knows
that there's a perfect bra for everyone
so right now they're offering our
listeners 15% off the first order go 2/3
love.com slash morning toast now to find
your perfect fitting bra and get 15% off
your first purchase
that's third love.com slash morning
toast for 15% off today third love.com
slash morning toast Thank You third love
for sponsoring this episode on raise
those breasts this is the last time
it'll be the three of us on the show I'm
deeply depressed last time out you'll
read an ad and I will smile at snitch
it's just a lot of last time so it is
but we have work to do we ever stated
shaving is coming you have any questions
for her please leave them on the YouTube
stream she's here to talk Bravo con new
seasons of Shahs of Sunset she's a new
baby we have a lot to talk to her about
we will be right back with her take a
break go get tickets to the dirty jeans
tour car with no job calm and then come
back again and I'll be back
you
okay we are back with one of my favorite
human beings on the face here you've
been on our show before but never live
we've always had a podcast with you yeah
this is live this is live oh yes my you
could curse you could say whatever you
want as I did say the c-word earlier
someone call me fat and they they had to
be called the c-word I am sure hunt yeah
you are in town for Bravo con right yes
there is so much chatter about Bravo
crowd like people the city is ablaze
like how many there must be grab a
Liberty's flown into town right 88
really 70 85 something like oz besides
you it's all the OG Shaw's oh so Mike
you Reza coolness oh that's a yes
Ferrari that's so fun and yeah telling
us about your event it's like a game
show thing right my show yeah my event
is so fun it's gonna be a family feud
what do you call it format yeah hosted
by Jerry OC him and it's gonna be me
Stassi Tinsley Mortimer who I haven't
met before
oh cool Kate Chastain who I've dated
scary kidding I took her out to dinner
last monthly she's doing pickups to her
logic excuse me sorry I don't mean a
smush my Mike yes because below deck is
not a toxic you're not gonna feel dirty
after watching it you're gonna need a
shower or therapy you know what I mean
that's why it's yeah and yeah diem lytic
med you so good love Nana okay and then
who are you playing you playing boys
right Mike Schuh head Jax Taylor Austin
crawled so good and I can't remember who
else would be but you know not memorable
no so Austin I'm sorry I don't you guys
watch right so cute yeah so I don't know
how you feel about him and Madison
Madison and Shep where do you stand on
that I feel like there's so much we
don't know
I totally agree cause Shep can't hate
her just because of what we've seen Shep
he can there's mortal tipsy yeah he let
like his whole like opinionated old
grandmother old school like a little bit
offensive a lot yeah and a lot of
leaders fans yeah yeah that's the man
the main offense yeah yeah I agree um
okay I mean I feel like every time I see
you I'm begging you for questions like
when the [ __ ] is the next season of
Shahs of Sunset
yeah and I know you guys are a little
delayed because when I saw you you were
on bed rest right yeah when you and me
yeah show in LA yeah that was the I
graduated from bed rest and I went to
the salon and yes and my extensions that
came to my ass they were beautiful and
yeah hair talk USA so you had postponed
they had postponed filming for you right
I believe yes we went from like what
would have been Jan no just top would
have been start of February but we
waited until the beginning of April
right so I guess that means also that
the premiere date is pushed back to a
little bit yeah we're hoping that Bravo
will announce the premiere date we
honestly I don't have it I wouldn't
withhold besides like the second that
they tell us yes we're able to like
obviously we're excited about it I think
that chance of sunset no matter that I
have been a loyal day one she has yeah
and I preached so hard for it because I
think it's the best show it's the best
show cuz you wanna know why I think of
all the shows it's maybe one of the only
ones where you guys were friends before
and your friends off-camera like
sometimes a new season of Real
Housewives will start and everyone be
like oh I haven't seen you and you know
the last time I saw them was the reunion
like yes you guys are trying to started
to get used to that I noticed that they
would premiere an episode of any of the
friend of the housewives and they'll be
like yeah haven't seen her in seven
months
yeah yes I think that Shahs of Sunset is
so successful because you guys are
really like they show pictures of you
guys you and Reza in high school like
there is real history there yes and it's
not it's not that's why when you guys
fight it's like so much sadder and
harder because there's real friendships
um and so I just gotta know I gotta know
who's coming back like I don't think
we've even been confirmed you guys
destiny was a newbie Nima was a newbie
and I really like I turned on Nima so
fast like I really just towards a head
really start to dislike him okay no
you're gonna change your mind about
everything really it's it's so
unpredictable like this is definitely a
major shake-up and you're gonna like I
don't know who's Nina on the show does
my a mile are you trying to get me fired
someone new oh yeah you're definitely
gonna see some new faces
okay you're sure I just think like that
sunset is at the center of like so many
cultural moments like I can't believe it
we know about Lilly ghalichi because she
was on Shore easiest thing and I love
that there's so many other cultures that
are not Persian and relate to us and you
know we connect like the fact that you
guys are Jewish persian-jewish is a very
big part of our culture as well so it's
like we're all very connected and I know
so much about Persian culture like I
remember I was in LA when I started I
was just finishing on the plane the
reunion and I just knew so much about
like Persian culture and it was the new
year and I was like oh gee of the table
with all the different things and it
really like you guys are like I know
it's like it's a fun reality show but
it's actually like an important it's an
important show you know I think it was
like the only television show that
really talks about especially when it
comes to parents and children there's a
huge presence of that family dynamic in
our age group I mean I know you guys are
a little bit younger but at the same
time the relationships that you have the
way that they're complicated the roles
that we play I mean it's really
important for me to see that yeah and I
don't really have a lot of places where
I can tune in to the like turn on my TV
and find the like the dynamic between my
mom and me yeah it's so relatable I
think for a lot of people it's mom or
grandmother or aunt or overbearing like
whatever Dallas yes yeah actually it's
so funny so funny the only type of show
where you can like laugh and cry like
it's it's really great but I think a lot
happened like as a consumer who doesn't
know you guys are filming I was seeing a
lot of stuff like in press and on social
media you guys were like really taking
it off mine like there was a lot going
on on social media between you and Reza
like where are we where do we stand I
think it's really hard for things that
you're living it's our real life you
know so with social media it's hard to
keep everything controlled and you can't
control like what the media puts out or
certain things that yes
but we're just very much in it like you
said it's a real relationship and we're
I mean I'm 100% going through it I just
gave birth six months ago right every
day is like an insane roller coaster
well and it's amazing and it's amazing
and there's so many like new new things
and firsts that happened right I'm sure
it's a lot different for you this year
because yeah you're a mom and I can tell
you guys like until and I know this
might sound a little preachy to people
who might not be into having children
but when you guys have children because
I know that you guys will it is another
level of living like the way that I look
at the world is through a completely
different lens and it's like it's such a
beautiful experience and your moms are
gonna experience being grandmothers
which my aunt just told me is amazing -
like it's how is Vida as a grandma
amazing yes so in love with him oh
that's sweet do you feel like you guys
are closer now yeah I'm starting to see
like her nurturing him so I'm like oh
she probably wanted to do that for me I
mean Tommy you're just the cutest I have
to say Paulie tell me on Instagram is
one of the highlights of my day
he's funny if I had to if I could only
follow top 5 you think you and well
you're private now I noticed yeah she
does I notice that we can definitely
have my mind go deep into that yeah day
yeah oh my god ok can I take some
questions for you for Instagram we have
tons like I'm telling you the toasters
or the Shahs of Sunset number one fans
thank you toasters how would your
puppies adjust to life with a baby so
Julio is a little jealous so he has
become very very high-maintenance is
there a camera okay Julio will
potentially lift his leg on something
that belongs to baby Toya is amazing
Toya is and you know she's only four
years old so they're gonna grow up
together shams his best friend nicest
thing I know please and she stays in her
Lane and they're very safe um is Gigi
pregnant she announced it on her
Instagram yeah um
you're scary I heard a rumor and I was
like that's amazing but like I didn't
know if it was true did you find out
from her from Instagram oh no we know
she was pregnant
okay that's great yeah yeah it's also
something you'll be able to see her
journey from pregnancy journey on the
upcoming season whenever they announce
the date that was the number one
question we got it's like when is the
[ __ ] so yeah I would say like any
second now they would probably put out a
date or like a super cheese or something
yeah so you can't spill too much but at
the present moment just tell me this are
you in Reza's good no I can't speak that
but no you're not gonna yeah I'm all
right
I you know but that's like that's really
upsetting because like you guys for the
most part over the course of it sound
way more like eight season like you guys
have been really good there was one
little riff when Lilly ghalichi like
tried to come between you to him I
couldn't just no one was here for it and
it didn't happen but if it's now real
it's very sad yeah do you feel sad yeah
I [ __ ] - of course yeah I mean I
don't want to like harp on it but like
weird this is a real show these are real
relationships and this is you know very
much something that's crazy that I'm
living out in front of a camera yeah
it's another like thing like and that in
the same year that I had it's just like
so my dad I'm definitely going through
it do you think though I know he talks a
lot about having kids like maybe when
that time comes for him like that could
bring you guys back together like you
said it changes people I mean it's
really important for you to keep your
heart open you can't turn into like a
bitter person and hold on to anger like
that takes too much energy you know okay
we have so many shady questions for you
like I think I I'm literally having to
like dodging landmines because I don't
want to be associated um just might feel
any type of way about Jessica's new life
he's super loving and supportive okay
guys Mike is very in the bottom of his
heart even though he can like put his
foot in his mouth sometimes which we all
know he does yeah but he is to the core
a very kind person that wants the best
for everyone I believe that I believe
that too and they feel like that comes
through
yeah yeah but I just think sometimes
he's like a little too like in his own
head like one you still have an ego yeah
even we as women we have pride ego so
like there's probably like some emotion
when you see the person he thought he
was marrying and spending the rest of
his life with her he really did so like
now here is if he sees like things like
I'm sure they speak one-on-one anyway
hopefully would yeah um okay so Tommy is
not Persian but what is his favorite
thing about Persian culture um you know
we have a lot of similarities he's half
Italian half Irish it's very similar the
food and the being really
family-oriented because he's friends
with all of his childhood people so I
know that he sees like strong roots and
family values and that's what I think he
loves the most
yeah I think that's what I would agree
with - that's what comes through most on
TV like you guys are so close with your
parents and it's so nice to see like
adults who still respect their parents I
mean reason why I'm moving to New York
is because of his whole side of my
family like that's why I feel like so at
home with you guys but also yeah all his
like people are here and the same
relationships from his episode when you
guys came to Queens like you were at
that bar it is like it was little Queen
you the queen of Queens the best episode
I wore this house of C be like crushed
melted greenvalley than any dress I'm
like right in it okay mo lunge wants to
know MJ look amazing can you tell us
about losing weight after having a baby
so okay this is a thing like this is we
have to stop and talk about this for
five seconds please
um I want to what's the person's name mo
mo I want to say that it's two things I
do want to get and be my best so get
active and at the same time I don't want
to miss any time with my son so it's
been a struggle because how I spend my
mornings can just it's very
unpredictable it's my first so I don't
have a lot of like ways to like see what
this morning's gonna be or next month
the important thing is that yes I'm
totally excited about getting really fit
losing all the weight that I've gained
even during the IVF process when I was
harvesting eggs and like gaining 17
pounds and not caring or being happy in
a relationship and not caring but at the
same time like I said it comes down to
being your best so loving your
and being kind to yourself no matter
where you are is all that matters it's
so great yeah so it is the most
important for me to say I'm gonna count
my blessings I'm gonna be grateful about
and have lots of lots of gratitude about
everything in the moment and not let me
go down this lane of like yeah I also
want to lose pounds and make my fitness
a priority so just it's such a great
mind such a great way to think about it
like I feel like that's very healthy I
have for instance you guys I brush my
teeth in the shower most of the time
because I'm in such a hurry mm-hmm so
today because I was here I was like I
brushed my teeth at the sink and I get
and I get this well where I was like you
need to do that more often yeah go ahead
and yes I agree yeah and so the little
things the self-care and baby shams is
here in New York right baby shams and so
we're at the palace it's his first trip
to New York yes it's his first time on
in Christmas in New York was he good on
the plane okay he treated my lap like a
trampoline and didn't and I had to
simulate simulate that I was holding him
and walking on me like walking around
but while I was seated cuz like the
signs were still on right that seatbelt
it's rough I'm not looking for to the
flight home it's an hour longer yes we
just I just need to talk about Shahs of
Sunset like I love to speak about it in
general terms cuz I think it's such a
good and important show and it's been on
the air for so long and they feel like
you guys have really good consistent
ratings and it's like I'm just really
I'm happy to be a fan of the show and I
can't thank you enough for putting your
life out there because I know it can't
be easy and I don't think I would ever
do it having said that Bravo was just
huge Network and there's always
celebrities coming out and being like we
love you know housewives in there I was
going on watch happens I was saying how
much they loved Bravo what is the
coolest or who was the coolest kind of
experience you've had with someone who's
super famous and watches Bravo oh my god
anytime someone comes on to watch what
happens and talks about Shahs so we
freaked out yeah Rianna
puffy like it's when like there's
someone that you really literally didn't
think knew you existed in the world and
they're obsessed with our show and they
relate so I love that like he at the
the day is like in his bathrobe kind of
tuning into the culture because again
like the richness of so many different
cultures throughout the world connect
with us yeah yeah I'm thousand percent
and you guys kind of tackles like
important hot-button issues but like in
a very calm and peaceful way yeah yeah
like when you guys went to Israel like
you guys are having just real
conversations about it was right
actually kind of like an important
conversation and the conversation you're
not seeing anywhere else like it people
talk about it but like you guys are
living living it like why wait to Turkey
IDM do something about religion do
because we're Jewish Persian we're
Muslim Persian were Baha'i we Christian
and part of your identity as a person
for me personally is torn because a we
can't go back to Iran B we'd like
potentially be beheaded or whatever
happens we went to the border that was
so crazy yeah and it's still like such a
big part of our lives like could you
imagine if you could not visit is really
that would be considered as a big loss
yeah you know so you we have to preserve
it in different ways as we can which is
like through storytelling and like you
get keeping it rich but yeah and I think
you guys do a good job of that but I'm
sure there's people in the Persian
community in LA who don't like the show
know all the Persians are like they
should have more engineers and it's like
those Iranians have either an
engineering degree where a logically or
they're an MP and so we're not the best
representation sorry Bravo's over lean
Bravo though that's not our phone so
funny and how to save the Persian people
I know that's like such a Persian
response like switch the channel I'm
sure it's you
which one some like the science planet
or what engineer went on the show then
they become famous and then they do
remember and say exactly it's actually
crazy how big of a part Instagram plays
in your show in particular I feel like
it's always a common theme and that's
where a lot of the arguments start like
GG cropping my kind of a photo like yes
always and you feel like if it wasn't
such a big thing you guys would argue
less well no I think that our
relationships are really troubled
because of the ego it's all
like someone taking something way too
personally and hurting the other person
deeply and one of us is usually standing
there going like why is that hurtful and
the other one of us is standing there
going are you kidding me I could have
cut deeper yeah so that's something that
like we're still healing from I feel
like I have to go in like Mother Goose
and be like we're all gonna get along
but like you know it's like not all the
time
you can't yeah I just remember punch I
wish I could just wave a wand right
right and make everyone agree with you
that's how I feel I just remember
podcasting with you a year ago and we
were really commending you on being so
brave on you know talking about your
fertility issues and that's why it was
so we were so upset with AUSA because
she wasn't being honest about her IVF
and I think that how the way you went
about it was really brave and I just
came live now we're sitting here a year
later and you have a baby like we feel
so full circle like I feel a part of it
yeah we're invested I think a lot of
people really commend you for that well
thank you it's really I was doing a
podcast that was just about moms and
motherhood and that journey and I don't
understand why people would want to hide
anything that another woman can learn
and experience from because that's how
we learned today it's like I need to
tune in to connect with other women in
order to be able to grow right so that's
why AI think it's really important not
to conceal those things and what's the
reason for it and if there's any
negative or if there's a stigma then
like like defuse it get rid of it react
about it have you met AUSA's baby no no
no there's a lot of that I wish people
could have seen like more footage and
more of like the story between the two
of us and so I wish her well but there
was a lot of kind of like final like
nail and coffin moments for us yeah for
me it was at that luncheon israil was
she said she had an embryo like it was a
boy and nobody yeah I was shocking it
was shocking for me because she was
calling me every single day talking to
me about it for three and a half hours
and asking me yet sharing nothing even
though she was going and then later Reza
told me that like she was going at the
exact same time and we try to make sure
she didn't run into me and again you're
not wanting to share it with the world
cause like that's a brave thing to do
but sharing it with you when you were
being so open like I thought that was
kind of yeah just talk about it yeah it
was like hard because when people are
like they if some
says that I was nasty which I was really
hurt and so the way that I like
communicate hurt it comes out angry and
angry is not like a winning you know
trait to be expressing when you yeah
when you're feeling of some kind of way
yeah
but the your you were talking about IVF
yeah yeah it just got it yeah it's great
just anywhere you are now that's why I'm
so excited it's like we get on the
journey with you from your mom like
yelling at you to freeze your eggs like
now you have a child like it's it's so
cool and more women should freeze their
eggs and not wait until the last minute
the only thing is like when Salma Hayek
got pregnant at 43 I thought that was a
message that I had time and some 30
year-olds need to like get the process
started before it you know times out so
that's an important thing to remind
people before we let you go I just have
to let you know and if you could tell
Tommy that probably my favorite moment
of any season of housewives is you're
walking down the aisle and he comes and
he goes you cans look sick me I might my
high school group of friends like we are
a sassy Shahs of Sunset and literally
every time we see each other but like
your face look like piece of wood is
probably the best thing you were walking
down the aisle was like a mean greet
you're like you are just so great I love
you I'm so happy for you
I can't wait to tune in to the new
season of Shahs of Sunset if you're
going to Bravo on this weekend make sure
to check out mo it'll be fun it'll be
really fun have a good time thank you
guys so much we are no tomorrow so
weekend I'm gonna be in Pittsburgh and
Philly this weekend I can't wait to see
you there tickets available two three
genes cards no job calm thank you so
much i listening to the morning show
some money morning show we go live
minutes a Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time
on YouTube we also have a loss of
pockets pretty much anywhere podcasting
we found Spotify iTunes stitcher
subscribe leave the five star review
about how beautiful setting and skinny
we are we love you so much
have a great weekend don't drink and
drive Jeffrey Epstein didn't kill
himself by
you